on this sunday night ida bashes
louisiana
hurricane winds reached 240 kilometers
an hour this is a major
major storm that's going to test us in
ways that we've not been tested before
in a state that's had to bear its share
of storms america's new adversary in
afghanistan the u.s launches another
drone strike on isis k while nato allies
negotiate with another dangerous enemy
to get people out of the country
[Music]
more protests meet the liberal leader
but justin trudeau is defiant on the
campaign canadians won't back down and
neither will i you got spunk and the man
who played mr grant wasn't just an actor
ed asner was an activist too
[Music]
global national with robin gill
good evening and thank you for joining
us a flood of memories has come rushing
back to the u.s gulf coast hurricane ida
a powerful category 4 storm made
landfall in louisiana this morning on
the anniversary of hurricane katrina the
winds were strong reaching 240
kilometers an hour and power has been
knocked out in parts of the state some
residents who've been there before are
getting out but as jennifer johnson
reports some are risking the dangerous
storm and staying put
with powerful winds and heavy rains
hurricane ida is battering louisiana's
coastline
oh my god
16 years to the day hurricane katrina
destroyed the region louisiana still
hasn't recovered from five storms that
hit in 2020 but widespread destruction
is expected again from this hurricane
any one of those areas you can get that
catastrophic damaging wind structural
damage power outages trees down
significant hazards on the road
ida is expected to bring at least 50
centimeters of rain and a storm surge of
four meters floodgates put into place
after katrina have been closed to try
and protect the area south of new
orleans modeling shows levees are
expected to hold in other places the
city distributed sandbags for residents
to guard against rising waters
there's been about a 14 billion dollar
investment since hurricane katrina over
the last 16 years but in less populated
low-lying areas some levees remain
unfinished
business owners are hoping for the best
i've been two days now boarding up
a lot of buildings a lot of buildings
getting ready
crossing our fingers hundreds of
thousands of residents who survived
katrina didn't want to see history
repeat itself so they hit the roadways
and got out
we decided to take off yeah because just
like with hurricane katrina
we're not trying to be here for the
disaster so
we ain't taking no chances we're leaving
but many in new orleans and surrounding
st charles parish decided to ride out
the storm even though the area is under
a mandatory evacuation order after it
was all but destroyed by katrina most of
my neighbors are staying i'm staying ida
is hitting a region already reeling from
a cobin 19 resurgence with low
vaccination rates new orleans area
hospitals are almost all filled up with
little to no room for people who may be
injured by this hurricane to the people
of the gulf coast i want you to know
that
we're praying for the best and planning
prepared for the worst ida is one of the
most powerful storms to ever hit the u.s
striking a region all too familiar with
devastating hurricanes
jennifer johnson global news washington
let's bring in global meteorologist
yvonne shell yvonne this is one of the
most powerful storms to hit louisiana
how did it get so dangerous robin it
strengthened overnight and with it we
saw those winds anywhere between 100
kilometers per hour and then doubling
closer to 200 kilometers per hour as it
were as it strengthened and moved along
some of the warmest waters and these are
the northern half of the gulf of mexico
a great shot that was captured from the
space station this was sent out on
twitter from hurricane ida and now we're
going to continue to watch it we've had
those winds exceed anywhere between 240
and the gusts of up to 300 kilometers
per hour category four and it's still
going to work in a northwesterly
direction we'll still see those gusts
over 600 200 kilometers per hour rather
and then as it weakens we are going to
see the biggest threat especially the
storm surge anywhere between 12 and up
to 16 feet and additional rainfall
amounts roblin will range between 50 to
100 millimeters
all right thanks yvonne
the other big weather threat is
hurricane nora which has now weakened to
a tropical storm
nora is battering mexico the storm has
caused flooding and landslides turning
soldiers into rescuers many people
living in the area are struggling to get
out nora has hit the popular tourist
areas of puerto vallarta and mazatlan at
least two people have been injured and
six fishermen are reported missing at
sea the remnants of the hurricane are
tracking north
the security situation in afghanistan's
capital kabul remains extremely tense
tonight earlier today the u.s military
carried out a drone strike against what
the pentagon says was a vehicle carrying
suicide bombers this is what remains of
the vehicle after the strike it's the
second coordinated attack by the united
states following last week's suicide
bombing at cabell's airport that killed
at least 169 afghans in addition to 13
u.s military service members
today u.s president joe biden and his
wife jill traveled to dover air force
base in delaware to pay their respects
to those fallen service members they
ranged in age from 20 to 31. biden met
in private with their families he's the
fourth u.s president to bear witness to
a military ceremony honoring soldiers
killed in afghanistan
at capitals international airport u.s
military planes continue to fly in and
out of the country these are some of the
last flights faring people out of
afghanistan ahead of a tuesday deadline
to pull american troops out the u.s
state department released a statement
signed by nearly a hundred countries
saying the u.s had received assurances
from the taliban that people with travel
documents would still be able to leave
turning to the election the leaders are
setting their sights on quebec hoping to
win over voters in a province critical
to the campaign conservative leader erin
ochoa got down to business pledging
support for canadian entrepreneurs but
as michael couture reports some analysts
say his plan has gaps
we're also going to have the rebuild
main street erin o'toole is trying to
frame his party as the only one standing
up for small and medium-sized businesses
the quebec bowling alley used as a
backdrop was closed during the pandemic
and the owner took on significant debt
the conservative leader believes his
plan to rebuild canada's main streets
will be a strike with voters we will
introduce an all new rebuild main street
tax credit it's a 25 percent tax credit
on amounts up to 100 000 for anyone that
personally invests in a small business
the tories also plan to offer a more
generous version of the kennedy
emergency business account loan
including interest-free loans of up to
200 thousand dollars we will make up to
25 percent of these loans forgivable for
small businesses
this will help struggling businesses get
back on their feet and create jobs the
canadian federation of independent
business applauds the plan pointing out
more than 800 000 canadian small
businesses use the pandemic emergency
business loan the average small business
has a hundred and sixty thousand dollars
in fresh covert related debt and that's
going to mean that it's an anvil around
their necks as they reopen one thing
this plan doesn't cover is the growing
number of home online businesses or
so-called micro-sized businesses those
programs remain locked down uh and only
available to mature businesses that have
been around forever
the conservative platform uh doesn't
speak to changing any of the eligibility
requirements neither does the ndp
platforms pressed on why microsized
businesses aren't part of this plan
o'toole sidestepped the question we want
people working in all sectors of the
economy and in all regions of the
country and we're going to work
relentlessly to achieve that dan kelly
says the cfib is pushing all parties to
include small and micro sized businesses
in these platform proposals so that they
too can get help as they try to get
through the pandemic
robin michael couture in 12 riviera
quebec
liberal leader justin trudeau has just
arrived in montreal after another
volatile campaign stop in ontario this
morning trudeau was making his first big
climate announcement of the campaign but
once again it was delayed and
interrupted by crowds of angry
protesters david aiken is following the
liberal campaign david
well rob in week three on the campaign
with the liberals began pretty much as
week two ended with a horde of loud
foul-mouthed protesters trying to
disrupt the campaign
liberal leader justin trudeau is the
lightning rod of their hatred he is a
coward
trudeau was the target of obscene chants
from a crowd where many brought young
children
shame on you
police were forced to physically remove
one woman though neither she nor anyone
else was arrested
but unlike friday's event in bolton
ontario when a similar group of
protesters forced the liberals to cancel
their plans out of concerns for the
safety of the participants the liberals
carried on with sunday's event the prime
minister of canada justin trudeau
even as protesters tried to shout him
down right alongside you
and yet asked if his team will change
the way they campaign to reduce the
chance of his security detail or others
from getting hurt trudeau seemed defiant
canadians won't back down and neither
will i the protest overshadowed
trudeau's announcement this one on
climate change there were no new
commitments or promises just a restating
of initiatives announced in the 2121
budget or elsewhere
green jobs
are good jobs and good careers
that's why a liberal government will
keep investing in clean industries that
power our future grow our economy and
protect our environment now looking
ahead to the week the big focus is going
to be on quebec all the party leaders
are there today for a media event
tonight and then a little guy then
they'll be back on thursday for the
first debate a french language leaders
debate now right now liberals are still
leading in quebec that hasn't changed
even if the even as they've fallen
behind the conservatives in ontario and
in bc and historically if quebecers are
going to start shifting their votes
it starts to happen after those debates
robin
david aiken in kitchener ontario thanks
david
ndp leader jagmeet singh needs the
quebec vote if he wants to recreate the
so-called orange crush of 2011 when new
democrats gained 59 seats today's thing
campaigned alongside ruth ellen brusso a
decade ago she was the party's success
story starting out as a paper candidate
and then rising up the party ranks she
was re-elected in 2015 but lost her seat
to the block quebecois in the last
election singh hopes presso will help
revive his party's fortunes in this part
of canada
there's the expression insanity is doing
the same thing over and over and over
and expecting different results people
we've always had liberal or conservative
governments and i think this time around
people are really excited and they're
going to be more open to an ndp
government
once again the ndp leader was asked if
he'd prop up the conservatives or
liberals in a minority scenario he
wouldn't speculate saying his goal is to
win the election
manitoba premier brian pallaster says he
will officially step down on wednesday
earlier this month palliser premier
since 2016 announced he would not seek
re-election he says he's leaving his
post now to avoid any perception that
he's influencing the leadership vote
progressive conservatives will pick a
new leader october 30th the party will
choose an interim leader this week the
next provincial election is slated for
2023. palestine says he will continue to
sit as a member of the legislature for
the time being
still to come he played a gruff
character in up and won in the mary
tyler moore show remembering ed asner
[Music]
there is trepidation across the country
as parents prepare to send their
children back to school for in-person
learning canada's overall vaccination
rate is inching upward but there are
still thousands of people who are not
vaccinated the delta cases keep rising
and children can't be vaccinated yet
here's global's montana getty
like students all across the country
jack hamm and his brother elliot are
getting ready to return to their
edmonton school with few regulations and
no vaccinations their mom lisa says
she's concerned but has faith in
teachers and the school system to keep
children safe i just think that there's
a bit more of a loose feeling this year
like a little bit less
fear and and just more preparation more
readiness and
a bit more of an ease
adults are getting vaccinated and that's
an important step towards ending the
spread of coping 19
but that doesn't mean kids are in the
clear according to nazi mahajarene an
epidemiologist at the university of
saskatchewan if you look back to a year
ago
end of august 2020
we were looking at numbers that were
probably in the order of about 40 times
fewer than what we are seeing this week
while bc manitoba quebec and ontario all
have mass rules for certain grades
species education minister says what's
different now is that majority of adults
including teachers are vaccinated this
year compared to last year when school
started months before the vaccine
rollout even began we are not in the
same situation this year as we were
heading into last september
because we now have safe and effective
vaccines that we know protect us from
covet but no province including b.c has
an across-the-board mask mandate for
children which is a big challenge
entering the new school years as
mahajarene so i think we have to really
do
all of the things we were doing a year
ago in terms of keeping our kids safe in
school
in fact i would say we need to do even
better for parents like christy
edwardson a mother of four from edmonton
all these rules are leaving them feeling
burnt out just trying to keep up with
the updates and trying to prepare my
children mentally of what's going to be
happening
um is it's it's hard some days you know
we all have goodness but you know i'm
tired back at the park jack and elliot
and their mom agree everyone wants to
get back to normal but the key is doing
it safely it's disappointing that we're
there again but
i think it is the right call
to take like masking precautions and
sanitizing and doing all that montana
getty global news saskatoon
still ahead a landmark ruling puts a
spotlight on systemic racism in nova
scotia's justice system
in nova scotia a new ruling by the
province's highest court is being called
an unequivocal win for the black
community nova scotia's court of appeal
has ruled trial judges must consider
historical disadvantages and systemic
racism facing black people during
sentencing and as graham benjamin
reports the landmark decision is just
the first step
there was reason to celebrate at the
delmore buddy day learning institute
after nova scotia's highest court handed
down a major legal victory i can say
unequivocally that this is a win for
african nova scotians last week the nova
scotia court of appeal ruled that judges
must consider the impact of systemic
racism at all stages of the sentencing
process the ruling involved the case of
rakhim rayson anderson a black man who
was found guilty on five firearm related
charges in june 2019. he was essentially
handed a community-based sentence based
in large part to the information that
the judge received through something
called an impact of race and cultural
assessment also known as an erka it
became about how we sentence african
nova scotians generally
and how we're going to begin to tackle
the issue of overrepresentation
of african nova scotians in the justice
system irkas were created right here in
nova scotia by local social worker and
sociologist robert wright who's
dedicated his career to lasting systemic
change through social policy advocacy
the decision came out i printed it and i
went for a walk and sat under a tree and
read it
and had a very emotional experience
rating anderson and his legal team
declined to comment saying that he's
looking to leave this matter in the past
for their part local advocates say the
significance of this decision should not
be understated for years dorico simons
with game changers 902 has been pushing
for reform in the province's criminal
justice system he's calling this a good
first step the next step is how then can
we treat and support and help a black
person
who has had a lifetime of inequity and
wright doesn't want irkas limited just
to nova scotia he wants them implemented
across the country making that tool
and the anderson decision
live
from c
to c
to c graham benjamin global news halifax
up next how to turn that pandemic frown
upside down
tonight ed asner is being remembered as
one of the greats the world has lost a
personality with all sorts of
personality
you
want to go out on a date
with me
yeah you're mine
asner is perhaps best known for playing
lou grant on the mary tyler moore show
he won five emmys as the crusty but
lovable newsman off screen he was the
president of the screen actors guild
from 1981 to 1985 but was accused of
politicizing the union he didn't shy
away from politics critical of president
ronald reagan's administration in the
1980s particularly on america's
involvement in el salvador's civil war
asner had more than 300 acting credits
to his name and worked well into his 70s
and 80s more recently in the animated
movie up
i'll send you a postcard
asner died in los angeles surrounded by
his family he was married twice and had
four children ed asner dead at 91 years
old
there's no question coveted 19 has
disrupted our lives now a canadian
survey is offering insight on whether
our social connections have held up or
not during the pandemic that can have an
effect on our happiness and as melanie
zettler found out one way to keep
smiling
talk to strangers
good afternoon
you a sagittarian no i'm a capriquarius
okay
hello
what's in your cup sir
coffee good choice
people who greet strangers at least once
weekly were three times more likely to
be happy than those who did not
according to a new survey conducted by
the gen well project in partnership with
the university of victoria in looking at
the relationship between happiness and
talking to strangers
one way to interpret it is you could say
a characteristic of happy people is they
talk to strangers so we don't know
necessarily which direction the
causation goes
but we do see this pattern in our data
that when you talk to strangers
you also report higher happiness the not
so happy findings 60 of participants
reported feeling lonely many times a
week almost half 46 report they felt
lonely every day the rate of loneliness
across all generations is above 45
on the more hopeful side it should come
as no surprise that the people surveyed
crave human connection hi everyone
hi
melody those around you are looking for
ways to connect we found that four in 10
canadians wanted to spend more time with
others
they wanted to have more friends whether
that's virtually
or whether that's outside on a walk
where you know risk of covet
transmission is very low canadians who
spend at least five hours per week
socializing with family were 2.14 times
more likely to be happy with more than
90 percent of canadians indicating that
they want to spend at least one hour
with their friends and family per week
and after 18 months of following public
health guidelines your socialization
muscle might need to be exercised
dexter
are you cranky
you look great you look very summery
melanie zetler global news
well we hope you had a happy weekend and
that is global national for this sunday
night i'm robin gill tonight your canada
is watrus saskatchewan thank you for
watching and i hope to see you back here
tomorrow until then have a happy night
[Music]